ce monde
avant quoi bien ok d'abord grâce à lui
si je peux le courant
je te donnais une technique infaillible
pourtant et oui mais c'est quand même
vachement impressionnant une fois mon
vieux tu dis pas pardon à l'ex en
question des 500 membres et leur côté
une bonne blague
c'est une blague zoophile ouais c'est
l'histoire d'un mec qui rentre dans un
bar c'est tout j'avais connu quand j'ai
un peu raté grands noms mais on était
coincés
bonjour non mais ya pas deux
bon qu'est ce qu'on a on a deux
individus parfaitement incontrôlable
chef
ils ont été observées en train de
discuter sans connexion à aucun réseau
social depuis combien de temps les a
perdus là ça se gâte plus de cinq
minutes
bon alors voilà ce qu'on va faire vous
allez sud mais aurait tout va bien se
passer
qu'est ce qui se passe tu t'enfonces
symbole temps de jouer à ce petit jeu
vous allez prendre vos téléphones
portables doucement sans faire aucun
geste brusque 1 maintenant tu mettais un
truc moi j'ai supprimé la fille bloquer
la situation est plus grave que ce que
je pensais
envoyez le hisse leiber ça c'était votre
code envoyé le is nigh peuvent envoyer
le sniper
ciblant jour réalisme belgique bon je
vous laisse une dernière chance on en
sait le fait qu'on en finisse alors
juste qu'on en finisse avec quoi
votre addiction à l'amitié non virtuels
à des vrais potes quoi ok envoyer la
notification
bon bon bon chef est fait pour vous
là
non c'est toi tu as laissé passer sa
chance